you were a very successful model for a
time I you know thought about entering
that business decided not to yeah it was
a whole Andy shut up he was a he was a
freckled model did you like that that
line of business being a male model
no I didn't love it no I find it um I
don't know what I find I just didn't
yeah it was good to me and it was really
and I and I respected for that and I met
some cool people but I didn't didn't
didn't feed me very much I didn't enjoy
the actual right of it you know did you
feel like they taught you mean every now
and then I feel like I'll see a magazine
cover this one's from a while ago but
it's you and Dakota Johnson I can see
you using your your model skills you
know in that in that shot and I'm
thinking did you did they teach you to
make that face or is that a face that
you you knew how to make naturally that
does a face that's born out of being fed
up I'm sort of going like why is he
lifting that part why she exposing my
arm like that yeah yeah I'm nicer to do
that right essentially you're trying
they always want you to look sort of
meaner than you are you know I guess I'm
not very like tougher diver so they're
always trying to make you look like
you're you know so menacing yeah so um I
feel like the best thing to do is
imagine you're looking at a very bright
light and someone's told you that
there's something really tiny in the
distance mm-hmm that you need to just
like focus on and that would be my good
sexy face if I did that I think you
should try it will work
will you show me how you do it to that
one day you show me first yeah okay and
I'll try on this one right here
I look like I'm trying too hard to make
out what that thing is that's my problem
no offense but the caption for each of
those is I can't read yes to the Jamie
encounter story well thanks for trying
with me yours was very successful
mine just looked like I had some bad
milk just like you just needed a fart
retention yeah
you